le 54e super bowl qui sera présenté le 2
février pourrait bien être le plus cher
de l'histoire pour les spectateurs 8900
dollar américain s'est presque douze
mille dollars canadiens c'est ce que
coûte en moyenne un billet sur les sites
de revente dix jours avant l'événement
les prix ont plus que doublé en une
semaine une surenchère qu'on explique en
partie par l'emplacement à miami leurs
crocs des hyènes compte 6000 sièges de
moins que les stades qui ont accueilli
sous provost ces dernières années moins
de place mais plus de demandes parce que
la température clémente de la floride
contribuer attire les amateurs de
football notamment sur kansas city
puisque pour les chiefs ce sera une
première participation au super vaut en
cinq enfants
en ce moment le billet le plus cher est
affiché à 92 mille dollars canadiens
[Musique]